Identification is session eight side and identification. And Frank actually joined us so we left.
And we went from there to below and yeah. And we had a great time in alone yeah.
And we didn't have to cook for so so much because we were welcomed. Different people who'd been to the system.
And I was so proud to be able to take us into their house for a bowl of soup or whatever.
And then someone say it happened it was Ellen said you know we're not awfully far from San Marino. And San Marino.
Incidentally was independent It had its independent government although in Italy as you know if
and they treasure I had a deli in the delegation that went to.
And we arrived at the gates of the city because it is you know is just a city on a rock.
And you have to through the gate to the city.
We pulled up and we looked pretty been there and the man of the guy you know who I was sore from Australia.
We were at Berlin at the first of all and he jumped out of the skin and he ran away
and he came back with the Treasurer. And the man here.
And the treasurer said Oh what a mutant did that then says an IT company. And the places we went up to the town.
And how tell you we looked we didn't. Look. Extraordinary and wait.
Been camping already for over two weeks and from nowhere.
The town hall is filled with women who is right at the banquet table with a huge class and cooking takes place
and wine for life.
And we're told to sit at the table and eat and being welcomed and the mayor makes a great speech
and the Treasurer makes a great speech and the Treasurer came up to me and he gave me a bowl of very that it will stay.
And I have them to this day.
So we had a wonderful time there and during the think it was like a banquet the food was very simple.
But cooked by these women you know homemade pester. You wonderful you know round about the make plenty of time.
I knew and god like it was heaven Heaven. So why Hine. There wasn't a lot but we had one.
So then we moved from San Marino entrance and Marina to row.
Frank is still being with us and acting as interpreter which is wonderful but she couldn't leave.
She just couldn't leave us and she said when the time was ready. She'd get on a train and go back to you know.
Well in Rome I was we were able to get to a proper bath house and have a clean up.
And see Rome and we spent almost two weeks there once again like a permanent chemical it's became the.
Then after a bit. I said well you know. Ellen said his boat was. The week before it was.
And we'd better not loiter too much. So I said I can't leave until I see Florence.
So we hopped in the car and packed up all our goods and shackles all at bully beef and whatever was there
and set off for Florence. And Florence was welcoming it was easier to camp closer to the city.
And Florence with the drug trade. It was nice and so cozy. So we spent about a week in the gallery.
And we'd made a lot of the talent for. So one day some of the students came to us. For breakfast.
And I said you know because it was very little food in Italy and I said everything will be still today.
There's going to be a strike and all of the workers will be marching.
So you must come
and get a good place where you can see it so they took us to a good place where we could see the match
and the marchers left that. Well certainly in the north and I carried these long rods. In front of them and I have.
Twelve a brace. And they apply. And. Quite a moving experience. Florence. Regrettably.
I felt I would like to have gone back again.
In the last six seven years or more since I've been there but I've been several times but the last time was.
And I found it almost broke my heart to see what had happened to.
You know to get into my punch punch you have to step over the. Well. It was very sad. So I said I don't want to see.
It made me realize. Deeply entrenched drug trade. Anyhow.
So we went back up to friends went to Cali and put the car on the back. On the ferry and went back to London.
And so I stayed in London until the week before Christmas I think it was. But during that time.
I think it was longer than. I have to check that. But during that time.
I met up with friends from Melbourne and there was the Reverend Vicki was a person or two people and could I.
An Austrian but he happened to be the private secretary for the Dean of Canterbury.
Now I met the Dane in nineteen forty nine here in Sydney when he visited and so Kurt said to me one day.
Look I'm sure I wouldn't be able to manage disappointed if you don't come down and see him.
So we said Bush would never do you mean had married again to a woman who was a beautiful artist
and he lit a studio who could be involved in running the place. And I had some servants who did that kind of thing.
So once again. BLANCHE. And Blanche was just a little more untidy than we were. Alan.
Accepted the invitation to go and visit on a Sunday
and we were to go to Sunday I didn't spend the afternoon just going around Canterbury. Enjoying it.
Then going to the early six o'clock service
and then we'd go to tea is his what you call it with the latest something like that. So I said. As you know. We're all.
And we have got to have to really think. And those days you couldn't go to church with. It will be gaps.
Because you'll be sitting in the visitors seat. If you please in.
Well we caught a picture I can tell you I had my you know the one that I had
when the pope was leaving yet so I was OK and that was something I could file that very little.
But they have this didn't have a head and I all borrowed the dean's wife so it's.
Well I don't know what we looked like but then we got to. What it would and did he cut it.
And of course he went only just been to China and he was telling us that.
That's how we should all be living a little he knew. How do you want to do a trip like that. You only see.
Their intellect you see what I want you to see.
And I learnt that from my trip you know that train trip from about the area going up to Paris made me realize that it
wasn't for one for the people who are divided economically. Anyhow.
So the dean preached about the wonderful things in China. And then when back to London and the next day. It said. Elf.
Dickey.
Here in London was one of them very courageous Presbyterian ministers who put it on them to stand up for world peace
and the banning of the atom bomb. And that was he.
And he had about four other Protestant colleagues who stood up against.
What they believed to be right and that was work for peace.
So they said to me up to Sheffield and do a bit of preaching about peace and be very nice if you could go
and give him a hand.
Well I was one of the regular peace exponents getting up you know platform so what have you saying how nice to have you
had a band and for the. To stop the manufacturing of ammunition. Well.
Ellen gets the brain back this time cleaned up a car after a quick trip in Europe.
And he said yes he'd be the driver
and he'd take us up to Sheffield because he was very involved in the peace movement and we got in
and we do so it was a Saturday we went up to shift the autumn when we arrived we had to go
and we were going to be housed in the rectory and the local. Rector.
Was considered a violent communist because he was involved in the peace movement right up to his neck
and he used to go out on the street you know.
Literature for peace and he said we were to go to his place we were going to stay there that night and we are high
and experience.
And his wife just took us in a group of lost children
and food case I cannot tell you you couldn't stand up in the streets of London because a cute phone behind you
immediately.
So we took a whole lot of tin stuff out of the boot which had been left over from the trip to Europe
and we took that in but had we not taken Haiti.
They were all going to we were all going to be fed on potato cakes
and I remember the huge wooden table in the kitchen to the our few servants around the place they were.
And they were all in big balls measuring the boiled potatoes.
And they had two wks and they were putting IGS into the potato cakes you know and making cakes for our two.
Well when we added that in staff it made it great truly.
But we had to wait for the main to come so well why did for the moment. Alan said let's go for a walk and we.
Truly open to the hardship of the minus and it as I said to us. This is but they have. So some who are coming.
Some of the leading miners who are coming.
We all want to have a bath before they come Saturday night but I have
but you couldn't see the houses so what you're suggesting like
and all the steps to the house you know two steps where why quashed white painted white. So you could see that state.
And they were common but the people waited and I would sit around waiting for that. And.
It was extremely depressing coming from places like Australia.
Where everything was so bright and cheerful even after the war the colors were bright and cheerful. Rist. All right.
OK so we had one tap and some of the leaders of the miners union came and joined us for tea.
With the potato cakes and all this. Feed the first. And she had also made beautiful Johnny cakes just went.
And we stayed there and we had a very big meeting with the miners that night and they.
And their children and they all said we've had it with you know what. We've had it now. Country.
They were a very progressive very progressive political that I knew the answers
and it wouldn't surprise me if at that time they didn't know about the row.
Because there was always doubt in the minds of the English people whom I knew about his worth. So.
And then we went back to London and in London. I went back to this lovely hotel.
It was a better a five minute walk to the what do they call the underground troupe to the to. And.
Being in London and I didn't want to see anything that had been bombed and had enough of that. So an awful lot of.
What was and I will consider all I brought to the ground in England doesn't matter.
And yes it comes Coventry and having seen that house it you know I've had enough.
So I'm going to see land and the place on it and the opera was beginning to function again in a small way.
I remember correctly because from where I was staying. I could walk to cover. But I spent a lot of time.
It's still my heart I mean I couldn't be bothered going near the place now than I mean it.
They don't sell of violets there they used to sell personality. Absolutely.
And you could come out of an early opera and go into your weekend shopping right there with good fresh vegetables ep
and all of the opera house practically so and the atmosphere is girl. You know it's not there anymore.
So I went back up there. He left to come back to Australia.
I do you know why in all I think about seven months or something like that
and I would not for one minute was I ever homesick. Not at all and. Beautiful and English.
And travelling on the same but it is me it was Frank
and Ross Harvey that was the any bet they could get on to come home and they were lucky to get around it
and so we came home had a cabin. And I shared the cabin with Shirley and Ruth. I would just Surely you know.
It was very comfortable the food was absolutely. Cooked until it was awful revolting. But nothing like that mattered.
You know.
Going to have a bloody good on the ballot and we did
and there were quite a few of the delegates on the trip coming back so we entertained he other passengers.
Played games and did all the things you do for six weeks at sea and they came back. And.
I thought it was wonderful going into the harbor.
But you know we had one and they're coming in at six in the morning in the little tags coming out to pull us in
and say you know for just beautiful. I would do any more this morning. I think.